SPEAKER: We focused
on a few key things
with Android Support
Library version 26,
shipping new features related
to text and animation,
improving parity with
the Android framework
and various form factors, such
as Wear and TV, and finally,
making the library leaner
by moving mean SDK to 14
and dropping 1.4 K methods.
So let's start by saying
what's new with text and fonts.
With Support Library 26,
we have simplified working
with custom fonts.
You can now use them
like any other resource,
placing them in a new
font resource folder.
We also now support
downloadable fonts,
meaning that you don't
need to bundle your phone
files in your APK.
Instead, the system
will fetch them for you
from a font provider such
as Google Fonts provided
by Google Play services.
Next up before texts, emojis.
You might have seen this
sad, blank, square character
whenever an app can't
display an emoji.
Involving Unicode standards
mean that the OS doesn't always
have an up-to-date fonts to
display the newer symbols.
With the emoji compat
library, your app
can get backwards compatible
emoji support on devices
with APL level 19 and higher.
You now have three widgets--
emoji edit text, emoji
text view, emoji button,
but also support for
app compat widgets
and helper classes
that allow you to work
with your own custom widgets.
Emoji compat can be configured
with either bundled or
downloadable fonts.
Check out the documentation
to find out how to use it.
Let's say that you want the
text size of your text field
to expand or contract
automatically
to fill its layout.
With Support Library 26,
all you need to set up
is the text view autosize.
You can control the granularity
to define a step size, together
with a minimum and
maximum text size.
Or you can provide a discrete
range of sizes to use.
Next topic on our
list, animation.
You can now implement animations
driven by physics forces,
so being velocity-based
rather than time-based.
This helps create a smooth,
natural-looking animation
that can correct its course,
when the target changes.
It also simplifies
hand-off between gestures
and animations.
We have two main types of
physics-based animations,
spring and fling.
Let's say you have a
view that can be dragged
around the screen, but
then when you release it,
you want it to go
back to its place.
Using a spring animation
will make the view
feel like it's being pulled back
by an invisible, but familiar
force.
You can customize the spring
stiffness, damping ratio,
and its final position.
If you want to animate
the property of an object
and you want the animation
to end gradually,
use the fling animation.
You can customize parameters
such as the starting velocity,
the friction, and the minimum
and maximum animation values.
If you're working
with vector graphics,
you'll be happy to hear that
some of the features introduced
in your SDKs are also part
of the support library.
Vector drawable compat has
a new property, fill type,
that determines which regions of
the image are inside the shape,
similar to the fill rule
property of the SPGs.
Animated vector drawable
compat has now the ability
to morph shapes and be fine
bath-based interpolators,
allowing it to create
rich animations that
work back to API 14.
Developing for Android
Wear or Android TV?
We have some good news for you.
The Wear online library has now
become a full support library
that contains some classes that
you might already be using,
such as box inset
layout, swipe dismiss
frame layout, wearable
recycler view,
as well as some new components
for action and navigation
drawers.
Several improvements have
been made to Leanback's API,
including a new video playback
element with seek support.
Check out the Leanback
documentation to find out more.
We have some other
notable changes
in this version of
the support library.
The percent support
module was deprecated.
So you should do its ratios
on the ConstraintLayout widget
instead.
And we have a new
PreferenceDataStore API
that allows you to implement
your own preference storage.
But also a behavior change
for our FragmentManager--
executePendingtransaction,
commitNow,
and similar transaction
calls are no longer
allowed during
FragmentManager state changes.
Fonts, emojis, autosize text
view, physics-based animation,
vector graphics,
form factor changes,
and others-- that's a lot
of APIs in the new support
library that allow you
to implement the best
experience for users.
To find out more, check
out the documentation page
and the Google IO talk on
What's New in Support Library.
[MUSIC PLAYING]